[Music]
any party that roots for Chloe and
Tristan yeah in a sneak peak at Friday's
episode of live with Kelly and Ryan Kim
Kardashian plays coy when asked about
her sister Chloe and her boyfriend
Tristan Thompson following allegations
that he cheated on Koko with multiple
women while she was pregnant I'm going
to yes I'm always really did I hurt ya
always really as your attorney
that's a great answer yes I'm always
rooting for family yeah yeah but the
reality star insisted that in spite of
all the drama Chloe is doing well
Chloe's doing honestly she's so focused
on her baby yeah
the guy is gorgeous yeah gorgeous so you
know I'm so happy now a source tells ET
Chloe isn't giving up on her
relationship with the NBA pro quote
right after the baby was born she almost
called it quits with Tristan but he
begged her back he professed his love
and apologized adding she never
envisioned herself as a single mother
she wants the whole package and she
isn't going to let Tristan's behavior
through in her lifetime dream
[Music]